we are going to spend a lot of the day
thinking about the way that digital
intelligence is going to change the
world and we thought it would be
interesting to take a moment to think
about how all this interaction with
computers might be changing us so we're
gonna have a brief conversation about
that question and who better to talk
about it then sherry turkle who's a
sociologist from MIT who spent three
decades looking at the way that we
interact with computers so sherry please
hi good to see so you've been on
something of an evolutionary journey
that I think it's fair to say that some
time ago you were a great fan of
technology and now you've evolved to a
point at which many might describe you
as a critic tell me very briefly about
that journey we have a problem with a
microphone you want to try again yeah I
don't think of myself as a critic I not
anti-technology I'm pro conversation so
my criticism really is of technology
where um if we were sitting together and
this has become something that just
people do I would say to you will just
hold on a second I need to check my
phone and then come back to you as
though I had put you on pause I mean
that's kind of my that's my kind of
criticism is where technology stands in
the way of the kinds of conversations
where intimacy thrives were empathy
thrives on in terms of my evolution how
I got started was being very pro and
excited about technology because i
thought the technology was starting a
lot of new kinds of conversations and
this was in the late 1970s at the birth
of the personal computer movement I
called the computer a second self
because I saw the way people were
really looking at what they put on their
screens as a projection of who they were
and had a relationship with these
technologies that really was more
intense and involved in the tip than the
relationship they had with cars or
stereos because they saw the computer
and their own computer really is a
reflection of their own minds but that
that is just enhance now that is more
the case now and yet you're feeling
about the effect that that's having has
become more negative well now we're in a
different space where the phones that we
carry the mobile technologies that we
carry are not just a projection of
ourselves but connect us you know with
the world of other people in ways that
paradoxically can interrupt our
involvement with other people and I
think that's the kind of paradoxical
moment we're at where we're just
figuring out how to make sure that these
phones keep us in contact with the world
rather than really cut short our contact
with the world so for example research
shows that if I put a phone down on the
table if we were having lunch two things
would happen what we talked about would
become more trivial at that lunch
because people wouldn't want to be
interrupted and so the conversation kind
of flattens out to more trivial things
and then also the parties and the
conversation feel less empathically
connected to each other so what you want
to do was not not use your phone but you
want to think about not putting your
phone out during lunch you want to think
about not putting your phone out when
you're having breakfast with your
children that sounds pretty hard to do I
can't imagine children listening to that
instruction no actually I found that
it's the other way around that i found a
generation of children who were kind of
tugging at the sleeves of their parents
asking for more attention so I'm
optimistic because I think the children
who were growing up now are growing up
kind
asking for attention from parents who
were often too preoccupied and this is a
generation of children in America which
is kind of very tech savvy can you
globalize this view at all or is it is
the research very much based on the
doors no I am globalizing this view
because I think the children desiring
attention and not getting I contact with
parents and not not feeling that they're
having the attention but rather are sort
of being you know kind of one in many
things that you know we have baby
bouncers that have a slot for an iPad we
have potty trainers that have a slot for
an iPad these are these are technologies
that are global technologies that are
being marketed globally and that these
are these are technologies that show I
think that we haven't put this
technology in its place because these
are moments where children need our
attention need eye contact need are you
know really full attention ok and one of
the things that's going to be discussed
today is also the movement towards
social devices that that take on the
role of a person and do things for you
and interact with you so that's a
different dimension on this how do you
feel about those well I would say that
the two technologies that brought me to
a more critical position we're on the
one hand the sort of always on always on
you technologies that we've been
discussing and then the second one was
the development of social robotic
sociable technologies that are of a
certain sort the ones that I think we
need to rethink or think very carefully
about are the ones that pretend empathy
because in all of the wonderful
intelligence that we've been talking
about that machines can have the thing
that they can't have and that I think we
interfere with children's development
when we pretend they can is that they
can't have human empathy they can't have
had the experiences that human being has
gone through and so as in my own
development of the researcher I began to
see machines that evoked in children the
feeling that they were
with machines that pretended empathy I
was also caught short and felt that
there was something to be concerned with
here but not just children also the
elderly because I think we have a
tendency to think that we can give as
companions for example machines that
pretend to empathy both to children and
also to the elderly and I think in the
case of the elderly um break our compact
with them to hear their stories by
people who can understand the stories
they're telling so I was doing research
with one woman who was trying to talk
about the death of the child and to a
robot that was pretending to understand
and of course it did not and was
heartbreaking I mean I suppose that
there are always replacements for human
empathy they thought they've always been
pets children have cuddly toys away with
which they empathize to a certain degree
so this is just a new dimension of it
and just needs to be handled in the same
way as we handle those other things no I
don't agree I a cuddly toy is a passive
object on which a child projects the
child's feelings so for example a child
who's just broken her mother's crystal
will put her Barbie dolls in detention
in order to you know have a chance to
work through her guilt on the doll that
she projects guilt onto so dolls have
always been a way to to play with and
deal with the child's own feelings if
you have a doll that comes to you
pretending to have a life pretending to
have a life have its own guilt you're
dealing with with something very
different and one that I think we have
to make sure the child isn't themselves
silence happily there's time for you to
explore all of this more in one of the
afternoon paddles the sunday but let me
just close and I have to please my own
time keeping better than everybody else
I guess but let me just close by asking
what would take it for you to evolve
back to a position of being very
positive I would be very positive well I
think actually right now what makes me
positive is I think
that we are becoming more sensitive I
see I mean list of course I'm talking
about my own country I think that the
generation who grew up with devices are
starting to put away devices when when
it is time to have a conversation and
are becoming more you know aware of of
not wanting to will to keep that break
and you know to not have that break-in
eye contact and to make sure the
conversations happen well thank you for
this device free conversation a device
free conversation thank you thank you